This video is for Read F10, probably my
most unhinged viewer of all time. This
all came about when I uploaded my rules
video about the Final Fantasy Saga rules
change. And I said that Blood Moon no
longer causes Öza Saga to get
sacrificed. And due to how layers work,
if the saga was on two law counters, it
would keep both the colorless mana
ability it gets in chapter 1 and the
construct ability it gets in chapter 2.
This led to some of the craziest
comments I've ever seen in my 10-year
content creator history. Comments like,
"Attack on cardboard. What's hilarious
is that you use the term sweet summer
child to describe someone who is smarter
than you. You do realize I can force you
to take down your video, force you to
make a new video to apologize to
everyone, and put you in a revolving
cell door for shaharaas and giggles.
Also, I can sue you. If you don't
realize that I can actually do all of
that and a hell of a lot more, then you
are a sweet summer child. I said I could
sue you, get you to remove this video
and force you to make an apology and put
you in a revolving cell. The last one
doesn't require legal action from me.
Attack on cardboard. It makes a lot of
sense now. How you
how you are so Öza stupid, refusing to
take responsibility/acountability
and misguiding morals. But okay, since
you pretty much gave me legal permission
to release your personal information
online, I'm just scrubbing your data.
Attack on cardboard. Oh, you do realize
a revolving cell door. The police are
not required to feed and or allow you to
sleep. Do you understand that? They then
go on to call me some other words that I
can't show in this video, but the last
comment they made was, "Attack on
cardboard. I see you're not making
videos of Moto that they mean Magic the
Gathering online where that's been
around for at least 20 Öza years again.
Haven't seen a video about the Blood
Moon effect yet. So, here I am in Magic
the Gathering online with a mono red
prison deck that features Blood Moon,
Magus of the Moon, and Öza Saga.
Okay, so we find a hand that has blood
moon and some card draw. So we'll just
wait till we draw the Öza saga.
[Music]
We then draw an Öza saga and play it and
the first chapter ability triggers
giving Öza saga the colorless mana
ability. We pass till the next turn
until the Öza saga triggers and gains
the ability pay to and tap create a
construct. Okay, so we have an Öza saga
with these two abilities. We play a
mountain and then we play a blood moon.
And oh, would you look at that? Ancient
tomb lost their abilities, but Öza Saga
kept both of theirs. Here we are
creating a construct.
[Music]
And here's the mana ability that the
saga has.
So there we go, Reed. Here's this
interaction playing out in Magic the
Gathering Online exactly how I described
in my video. For the rest of you
watching, if you want to learn why this
works, feel free to check out the video.
If you learned something, be sure to hit
the like button and subscribe because if
you don't, you'll have to deal with read
F10 putting you in a revolving cell
door.